do you think Alpha men like yeah Alpha
females don't Alpha men like want
submissive females but then Alpha
females can be submissive to the right
alpha male or to the right Mouse
yeah but you don't think there's a line
of men waiting today are women waiting
to date Alpha men like why would they
deal with an alpha female because they
wanted men don't want to date themselves
actually but no but then that's the
difference between a male and a female
because maybe then she'll submit because
she's got she'll give him the same run
for his money and keep his mind going
yeah but why would a guy go through that
when he could just go to a girl that
doesn't
exactly why do men cheat
someone like that and so yeah some some
men like to be taken care of as well yep
yeah I mean we can talk about exceptions
no no but that's what I'm saying because
an alpha female would still she could
she could still provide it she could
still she can still she can still hold
it down so maybe she can hold it down
for him
yeah guys don't care about your money
not in general I didn't say money I
didn't say money
holding it down emotionally for remember
because it's a lot for a man to
especially in Alpha matter to offload
his emotions onto somebody to show his
vulnerability I do believe that with an
alpha female he will do that because he
knows she can hold it down and she could
take it on board and not use it against
him that's what I just said that's what
I believe I think I know what she means
as well okay explain I feel like well in
terms of alpha female tell me if I'm
wrong I feel like when you say alpha
female you know there's some man out
there they like a girl I'll give them a
beer
let me give you
videos I can only speak for the guys
that are around me yeah
25 to like 40. yeah
so in between the age 25 to 40
. most men yeah I like that I'm not
saying they want that but there's a
there's a percentage of them men that
like the alpha female yeah they like a
bit of fight back do you think it's the
majority nah it's not it's a minority
it's a minority
yeah I found that's like more like men
that are like more feminine okay
I agree no I don't agree I feel like no
I I disagree I think
I've I've I haven't traveled to many
places but what I can say is being in
South Africa being in Florida and being
here in the UK
there will always be that kind of man
that wants that kind of woman and yes
they want the submissive woman but it's
like why do you have to be submissive in
public when you are who you are you are
who you are I am who I am what do you
mean why do you have to be submissive in
public can you explain that more it's
like some guys are happier when their
woman's just sitting next to them and
just smiling and not talking to any men
and not looking at any men's Direction
like not talking to females not talking
because your draw out you're gonna you
know like so and do you think that's a
problem I think when uh when a high
value man brings along a goal in public
I think that this a particular woman
that he brings with has to be quite
reserved so can I just say something in
in terms of the minority so that's
that's not your that's is that that's
your definition of submissive
just sitting there quietly and not
saying a word well no what I'm saying is
I didn't mean like sitting quietly and
not saying a word I just said reserved
but being seen and not heard yeah but in
a way where I don't have to talk because
my man's doing all the talking bad the
problem is when you meet the phony ones
who do too much talking and then you're
just sitting there like I think I've
submitted I think of submitting to
Authority like so so when you have a job
so when you have a job right you know if
you're if your boss says do this yeah
you don't spend an hour arguing well why
are we doing this like why do I have to
do this like no you just say okay and
you do it yeah so that's what I think of
when I think I submissive that's what
that's what I think that's what I think
that's what I think for sure
but then it can be also like the way
they say you can say it it's not do that
so so when I think what I'm saying is I
don't think sorry I don't think that
those men are
like
feminine they're not feminine you know
what I mean which ones the ones who
choose the alpha alpha women yeah
they're able to hold conversations when
they're not around babe I'm going to the
toilet cool I'm gonna have conversations
while you go to the right but it's not
about Converse it's not about
conversations it's about listening so I
just think those men they usually have
hard jobs they work a lot they work long
hours and they don't typically want a
woman that's not going to listen and
Alpha I've just found that Alpha women
don't tend to listen like it's my way or
the highway I'm the alpha I'm the leader
because what's an alpha that's a leader
a leader you can't have two leaders in a
relationship why would a guy that's a
leader want another leader yeah you can
do because
that's what we mean because at the end
of the day like someone has to make a
decision I don't think there's one
destination though I think this if
you're talking about being in a
relationship and having family there's
two Destiny there's a few destinations
that come together what are those when
you say destinations like as the woman
in the family like the mother she needs
to take care of the children take care
of the house the man and lead them and
Lead when he's not around but when he's
around
there's that sense of okay I can chill
for a second yeah but not a lot of men
can back that up I feel like I feel like
there might be some sort of like
misconfusion everyone's missing each
other yes
when you're saying different paths yeah
there's one woman that's gonna listen
sit back all right babes even if she's
got her opinion she's not gonna say it
yep because she just wants to just make
her man happy and get on with it and
have a happy marriage then you've got
the other woman that can be a leader
just like her husband however they're
both bosses and they come together as a
team thank you
I know many relations he's not
submissive but she's just understanding
she's got her Point as well they're
gonna come together at the end and
they're gonna meet at the final but
can't submit when it's winning that
makes sense it never makes sense not
really could you could you give me an
example of that I think I know I know
what you mean okay I can give you an
example that Jay-Z and Beyonce Beyonce
she's a leader she's a boss she's an
independent woman the biggest Capper
she's on the phone
because she's talking about she doesn't
need a man when she you know you know
it's music
but that's what I'm saying she's she's
busy brainwashing these babies
so when when her when she caught Jay-Z
cheating
was she an alpha female or did she say
you know what I mean no way she was an
alpha because she was like do you know
what bridging I'm submit to that one
actually but maybe
he was saying so as I said as I made my
point some women are understanding
remember we spoke about the other day
pearly some men if you're in the
entertainment business
you know the guy's gonna cheat she's
understanding am I gonna throw away this
Legacy I'm gonna throw away this
business or should I just get up with it
and throw it along you know what I'm
trying to say I'm not saying that she's
not a leader and a boss but I'm saying
there's some women that can be a leader
in the boss and be understanding don't
mean that they're not submissive yeah
you know what I'm saying you cut the
whole situation on lemonade like I
believe when I once I came out with that
lemonade album yeah I believe everybody
said no to their boyfriend and they ran
away from her boyfriend and then she was
like I'm pregnant with twins I was like
oh how are you gonna bring out the
lemonade
you just made me break up with my bad
dog
that's what people get for following
celebrities I've just never I've never
met a girl that calls herself an alpha
female yeah I really believe it's
submissive in a relationship yeah yeah
people take the word Alpha do you think
women can actually be out
Timmy no no no let's get into it please
because I need to understand I'll let
you yeah to me an alpha woman can be a
very strong woman who's just got her
together tell him again and she
knows how to take care of her man she
does her thing and she she gets on with
life and yeah she's a strong woman she
can do a bit of DIY she can do
everything you know I I've got four
sisters and let me tell you all my four
sisters can do more than me so can I
including DIY everything they can do
everything because they we I grew up in
a big family where my sisters had to
basically defend themselves and and they
grew up in the 90s in in White Chapel
green so it was a time where you had to
be strong you had to stand up for
yourself you would say they're more
modern than traditional yes but like
what has better outcomes
if the modern Alpha females had good
outcomes why are men getting their
passports and leaving a woman
because more time one minute more time
if you ask most of these men they were
brought up by a single mom wait hold on
so would they say that their mum was not
an alpha I just that's just what I'd
like to throw out because I'm sure if
they were raised by a woman who had to
hold it down for their whole family and
look after them and bring them all up so
it sounds to me like she sounds like
she's a bit so but so if he was raised
by a woman that doesn't know how to how
to have a functional relationship who
said she doesn't know how to because she
couldn't if she's a single mother she
doesn't know how to have a functionality
because those are the results
yeah so she doesn't know how to function
how to have a functional relationship
because
the the father of the child decided he
he was like no he decided I don't want
to be a dad and he walked out on the
child so she doesn't and she doesn't
know yeah because women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 of them
so she doesn't know so you're just the
same because she doesn't she doesn't she
she either picked someone like I mean
come on why would you have a kid with
someone that isn't gonna stick around
there are some men who will get a few
baby mamas and they'd visit one from
another and they kind of set up their
lives yeah so there are men who do that
and because the women are getting
financed or they're getting support
they're fine with it because they're
living their lives yeah but this is
accepted like you guys keep talking
about exceptions I'm talking about the
rule the majority of men don't have
multiple baby mothers yes one out of
three men are either virgins or haven't
had sex in the past I'm talking about
the rule not the exception and I think a
lot of girls will continue to talk to
these men even though they know they
have multiple babies
so we go back to your question your
question which is can't do single
mothers know how to have a functional
relationship no no I didn't say that no
you you asked if that's okay yeah and
I'm saying stand on that no in general
no other exceptions not many no no
yeah Bobby snow though I'll be real
though I'll be real
you see me like it depends it depends on
your environment yep your background the
community you've been raised on yes to
what you will see and what you will
visualize yes so we might see something
different to what you see and sign us to
what you see but I'll be real I don't
know if it's a small jury it's like what
because I know a lot of people are
single moms or fellow my friends
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible